I continued to experience vaginal dryness, which is worsening to the point that I dred into
the sea. I think it is called vaginal atrophy. I could try using a cream suggested by my thyroid
doctor, which contains a compounded vitamin A and E and hyaluronic acid and with a tiny bit of
testosterone. Would this be safe given by diagnosis of breast cancer? What are my options?
So from an alternative perspective, vaginal dryness or vaginal atrophy,
typically the recommendation would be bio-identical testosterone with a testosterone cream.
So is that a negative for breast cancer? The answer is yes and no. So there's a possibility
that excess testosterone will store in your fat cells and then through a process of the
robotization will break down into the quote-unquote bad estrogen. That could be an issue.
However, that could be managed and monitored. So there's also evidence that using testosterone
for with people with breast cancer can actually have great beneficial attributes. So I would say
absolutely go ahead with trying this cream. I would try to cream first because that's simple
before you try to get into compounded testosterone bioidenticals. I would go for this. I would
for sure do this. Yes.